[Music]
hey folks
welcome to the dark horse podcast live
stream
number 40 with a cat's ears
barely in the frame we
are facing the most remarkable stuff and
we are continuing to grapple with it
live with you all heather hing
how should we start today may we start
uh with a brief reading from the
cuddling of the american mind
excellent all right so this book for
those of you who don't know
by greg lukianov and jonathan height
the cuddling of the american mind how
good intentions and bad ideas are
setting up a generation for failure
was published two years ago this week
it's an extraordinary book it was based
on an article
in the atlantic of the same name i
believe
from a couple of years prior and um
pamela pereski who was their senior
researcher
on the book uh approached us along with
jonathan height
just as evergreen was blowing up to talk
to us about what what we were seeing
there
and so we were um we were privileged to
be able to
see this book as it was as it was
emerging
and excuse me um i just want to
briefly summarize a couple of their main
points and then
read a little bit from it so they start
by naming three what they call three
great untruths
which are what doesn't kill you makes
you weaker
what they call the untruth of fragility
always trust your feelings
what they call the untruth of emotional
reasoning and
life is a battle between good people and
bad people the untruth of us versus them
this of course is akin to what we've
been
calling the battle between the star
belly snatches and the sneetches without
that was cat chaos in the background if
you guys could hear that
so in this final section of the book
they
refer to those truths and they say okay
but
what what may explain them and they say
we present six interacting explanatory
threads
rising political polarization and
cross-party animosity
rising levels of teen anxiety and
depression changes in parenting
practices
the decline of free play the growth of
campus bureaucracy
and a rising passion for justice in
response to major national events
combined with changing ideas about what
justice requires
so all of those of course are um if
anything more relevant more apropos
today than when they publish the book
and you know they
of course books aren't written the day
they're published so when they were
writing this when they were first
seeing some of these things emerging on
campus in particular and they they point
to 2014
as a sort of a pivot point um and then
they wrote their uh
article in the atlantic i can't remember
if it was 15 or 16
and then this was published two years
ago and here we are today with
you know such extreme examples of
polarization on the streets and
and you know all of these things but
also to to look to their last one
uh changing ideas about what justice
requires
right so here they have earlier in the
book
on page 75 76
they describe a scene from
uh september 6 2017. so this would have
been after charlottesville
within a month or so of charlottesville
i think and
i just want to read to you the
description of what happened here
appeals to common humanity still work
just as well today as when dr king made
them
on september 16 2017 on the national
mall in washington dc a group of trump
supporters organized a rally they called
the mother of all rallies patriot
unification gathering
counter protesters from black lives
matter showed up and shouted at the
trump supporters
the trump supporters shouted back
someone on stage told the trump
supporters to pay no attention to the
counter protesters
they don't exist he said hawke newsom
the leader of the blm counter
protesters later said that he expected
to quote stand there with his fist in
the air in a very militant way and to
exchange insults
tensions mounted and onlookers recorded
video of the potentially explosive
situation
then the trump rally organizer who goes
by the name tommy gunn took the stage
it's about freedom of speech he said in
an unexpected move he invited newsome
and other blm supporters onto the stage
we're going to give you two minutes of
our platform to put your message out
gunn told newsom
now whether they disagree or agree with
your message is irrelevant it's the fact
that you have the right to have the
message
newsome took the stage i'm an american
he began
and the crowd cheered and the beauty of
america is that when you see something
broke in your country you can mobilize
to fix it
but then as he spoke about a black man
being killed by police the crowd began
to turn on him
they booed shut up that was a criminal a
woman shouted
newsome explained we are not anti-cop
yes you are people shouted
we're anti-bad cop newsome insisted he
still seem to be losing them
we don't want handouts he told the crowd
we don't want anything that is yours
we want our god-given right to freedom
liberty and the pursuit of happiness
now they were coming back around people
cheered someone in the crowd shouted all
lives matter
which is usually intended as a rebuke to
those who say that black lives matter
but newsom responded in the tradition of
paulie murray by drawing a larger circle
around everyone in the crowd
you're right my brother you're right you
are so right all lives matter right
but when a black live is lost we get no
justice that is why we say black lives
matter
if we really want to make america great
we do it together
the crowd cheered and chanted usa usa
in an instant the two groups were no
longer us and them
their ideological differences remained
but within that larger circle around
them their enmity melted away
and at least for a short while they
interacted as fellow human beings and
fellow americans
it kind of restored my faith newsom said
when interviewed afterwards
two sides that never listened to each
other actually made progress today
one of the leaders of bikers for trump
came up to newsom afterward and shook
his hand
the two men talked and then posed for a
photo together with newsom holding the
other man's young son cradled in his arm
so
that has many of the elements that we
recognize from today's protests and
riots and yet
has a a very different tenor in part
because
members of both sides the the would-be
leaders of both sides are willing to say
you have a space to talk here and we are
going to listen we don't have to agree
uh people on our side may yell at you
but
we're we're going to listen uh let me
compare that to today's rhetoric before
asking you to to comment
um on august 20th just a couple days ago
we received an email actually before i
say this i will say that actually right
now as we are
live right now in downtown portland
there is uh
a rally a set of rallies and a set of
counter rallies in downtown portland
uh between basically um
right of center protesters and left of
center protesters and i don't i
i think that at least one of the groups
right of center
is the proud boys and certainly one of
the groups left to center is
black lives matter and antifa that's
like two groups
with tight uh correlation um and
they are you know right now um meeting
on the streets of portland
squaring off which is something that
they have done regularly they
effectively announce one group announces
that it will be there the other group
announces that it will show up
and things um unfold from there i should
say i've attended one of these just to
see what it looked like on both
sides and in general
uh it is a contained
version of what is now uncontained
in portland but i would we'll we'll hear
about it we'll find out
um but i'll bet that today's events are
not as contained in part um this is
uh this is one of the first times that
the people from the right have declared
uh in advance that they're going to show
up for a while certainly i think
i may be wrong about this but certainly
um
the first time maybe in this 80 plus
days that the riots have been nightly
in portland and maybe um you know if
they showed up it was
at all it's been it was early unless so
um on august 20th today is the 22nd so
two days ago
we received an email from a viewer of
this live stream who lives in north
portland which is two blocks from the
police union building
on north lombard that has been at the
center of some of the protests and riots
in portland so there's sort of
four lar broad areas not large areas but
sort of four
buildings really that the protesters and
then the rioters have
have targeted and um the police building
on north lombard in
in north portland has been one of them
so this is a viewer who lives just a
couple blocks from that building
and he said yesterday these pamphlets
were placed on the front porches in my
neighborhood
it's blatant propaganda and some of the
verbiage is disconcerting at best
so i just he included uh screenshots and
not screenshots he took pictures and he
showed
us that so um we're going to show you
the zack would you show
the first of those four pictures from
the um yep and maybe just make a little
bigger so people can
can see it a little bit more okay it's
it's it's fine
okay uh so that's the that's the cover
um
next page uh
somewhere on this uh we can't we we
can't read this but somewhere on this it
says
do not expect peace from the police a
fundamentally violent institution which
functions to suppress
effective social movements that's a
claim
next page somewhere on this page it says
night after night police respond with
violent escalation
regardless of protesters actions another
claim
i think unfounded and final page
how you can help on the ground you can
leave water bottles out for protesters
you can provide verbal support from your
homes most importantly
you could join us on the streets there
is strength in numbers the more people
there are out on the streets
the less likely it is that the cops will
injure people
so just one more thing um before i ask
us to talk about this a little bit
zach if you would show the video um that
i
asked you to show from north portland
last night
[Music]
so that is by far not the
most violent of the videos from the
nighttime protests
slash riots in fact there is no real
violence there though
you might understand there'd be a threat
of violence but what they're saying
is out of your house and into the street
out of your house and into the street
which is of course quite not what they
suggested
in their pamphlet that they were
distributing to exactly this
neighborhood the day before
they were asking you to voice support
from your house which is itself an ask
that is
potentially a big one because it would
appear to be a kind of
payment that you must give whether or
not you believe it
um but the very next day what the
what the protesters who might later
become writers are
doing is demanding that you not merely
show support from the safety of your own
home but you get onto the streets with
them
so there's a trope built in here that
were you to see it in different context
everybody would get it a hundred
which is the veiled
threat it's not even a threat with
plausible deniability it's implausible
deniability where a threat is leveled
but it's done in a way that is
unprovable
you can't tell for sure that it's a
threat not at the level that it would
be required to prosecute somebody for it
but it's obviously a threat from the
point of view of the person
hearing it and so you know so out of
your homes and into the streets
that's a demand a demand being
shouted by people shining very powerful
lights
into people's homes imagine you were at
home and
an angry crowd that is setting fires
nightly in portland
is outside your windows breaking into
into buildings
police precincts yep night after night
um
and you know well you could report this
as uh protesters marched through
neighborhoods and
you know invited homeowners to join them
i'm sure it's been reported that way i'm
sure to the extent it's been reported at
all and i must say people
around the world who we're in contact
with have the sense that things are
calming down in portland
i see no evidence of that nope it's hard
to know because you have to the
protests are so concentrated that it's
not like the evidence is you know we
don't encounter it on the way to the
market or the post office or whatever
um but we were assured things would calm
down once
uh the governor and the mayor negotiated
uh that the feds would leave so long
as state and local police um came
forward and started doing their jobs
right they're not being allowed to no
but the point is okay so that's a
that's a implausibly deniable threat the
shining of bright lights into people's
windows
um and consistency that's
that's on the cusp of deniability right
uh is that could you show the one that i
had the similar looking
video from one of the last couple of
nights
now this one uh
we cannot hear
wake up wake up [ __ ]
[Applause]
wake up wake up [ __ ] wake up
wake up wake [ __ ]
all right you can stop it so without you
wake up wake up wake up [ __ ]
wake up okay right
now that doesn't sound like an
invitation
not really now it could be uh a
temporarily inappropriate wake-up call i
mean as long as we're doing
plausible or implausible deniability
maybe they think the people of north
portland are nocturnal
right who knows um but the point is
that's very threatening stuff
it's threatening to anybody who sees it
a lot will rest on the fact that you're
not likely to see that if you're tuned
into certain accounts on twitter you'll
see it you could
you know you could subscribe to those
accounts and you can see the stuff from
every single night
or the few accounts that those videos
are coming from
have been uh have been described
as uh unreliable because
they report the same kind of story all
the time
as if reporting the same kind of story
all the time itself makes you unreliable
when actually it's because we've got 86
87 nights now
of uninterrupted uninterrupted and you
know
i can't be certain of this but i think
that from the point that violence
showed up uh late it's been consistent
every night there's been
at least some um so okay you've got a
situation in which if you're tuned into
certain
uh if you're tuned in let's say for
example to
the portland subreddit
the portland subreddit is quite
consistent
in reporting that peaceful
protesters are out working hard
and being attacked by police
um ezra would be led to believe by that
pamphlet right
so basically you've got two stories
they're completely incompatible with
each other
right and one of them is just uh
absolutely insistent on the fact that
this is about
racial injustice that the demands are
reasonable that the response is
unreasonable
well and i mean there's just a couple of
tropes again uh phrases even that you
see
repeated over and over again that seem
to have lodged themselves in people's
brain
and that are just very effective mostly
peaceful
the vast majority of the time you can go
and you don't see violence and in this
particular case the fact that you can
predict it based on time of night and
you know position of sun in the sky uh
makes that an even less compelling
argument than it would be otherwise but
who who cares you know most war zones on
you know an average moment don't look
like there's much going on right
actually and most men actually this is
maybe this is too far afield and won't
like won't land for people watching but
i used to make this point when i would
teach animal behavior and
i had all these students streaming in i
love animals i really want to
watch animals do what they do and i say
okay you're going i'm gonna
i'm gonna you know have you be in the
field doing animal behavior and you are
going to recognize how boring most of it
is because
for the most part animals sit around
doing nothing just like humans do as
animals right
you know think about your own last 24
hours or a week
you know how often were you doing the
sort of thing that you would be excited
to see an animal doing
um you know and this you know the the
moments
and for humans you know maybe eating
would count because that would be
uh you know prey capture in a carnivore
but it would just be browsing if you're
watching if you're doing deer behavior
um you know how often are they actually
like having sex or engaging in
territorial interactions
or you know feeding their chicks it it
happens not very much
and so the vast majority of time is
spent
in this sort of you know resting state
just like with these protests that
become riots reliably
so we have not talked about this in
advance but of course i was
thinking the very same thing and i did a
few back of the envelope calculations
really yeah it turns out i don't i don't
i don't see anyone world war
one was 81
peaceful 81 yeah yeah world war ii you
got the receipts for world war
ii was more than 85 percent peaceful and
here's the one that really blew my mind
world war ii was was more peaceful than
world war one
it was more peaceful um the uh
presidential motorcade
in dallas in 1963 was 99.8 percent
peaceful it's just that one moment
just a very brief moment of not peace
yeah um so anyway yes these calculations
about how peaceful something is can be
very
misleading if you're not paying
attention to the objective which
actually is to wield power well
and i'm banging this drum all the time
but it's another form of enumeracy like
oh mostly peaceful
mostly doesn't mean when you think it
means there it's doing a job that is
rhetorical that is political is
achieving a goal
it's not actually describing something
that is meaningful in the way that you
think it is
yeah it describes nothing and it's it's
obviously completely preposterous it's a
phony story here
um and so all right um the
fact of us being unable to agree on the
basic facts of what is taking place if
you're paying attention to the portland
subreddit you get the sense that there
are protesters who are
under attack by the police that that's
what's going on
if you're paying attention to andy noe
or
this account uh bg on the scene who's
been documenting these things
that's where that first video was from
yeah you have a very different
impression now the fact is
the portland subreddit read it cannot
martial evidence
that these protests are peaceful in
light of the fact that what they do is
fail to report the part that isn't
peaceful so that's not really
it's verificationist it's
verificationist on the other hand uh
andy noe and bg on uh
the scene and these other accounts that
have documented this have
shown you evidence now it is possible
and i'm not saying that these accounts
do this it is possible to misrepresent
this as what is going on across portland
which is not true
or to you know or to show evidence of
pro of rioters being violent and not to
show evidence of police being violent
that is certainly a way
that uh that those videos could be
cherry-picked to create a narrative that
is not true
right it could be cherry-picked on the
other hand there's certain stuff here
that's just
very completely unambiguous and if you
have done what we've done which is check
in on what's going on in portland
it's very clear what's going on you have
a peaceful protest that precedes a riot
the riot is reliable
it involves arson it now involves
harassing people in their own
homes um it involves breaking and
entering
uh let's see zach do you want to put up
the uh
the fire
so we have nightly fires this one i
believe is from last
night again this is uh vg on the scene
this is a
what did that limescreen ever do to them
uh yes this was falsely reported as a
bird scooter it has now been corrected
to alignment oh i got it right you did
get it right you
nailed it that is some reporting on the
ground right there false reporting is
the wrong kind of scooter
wrong brand a scooter but i mean here's
the thing okay these things are being
lit on fire
um trash cans are repeatedly being lit
on fire this is actually releasing
toxins into people's neighborhoods this
stuff actually gets breathed by people
sure as well but what it's also doing is
releasing pent up energy
well sure you know so the the cover
story is one that some of the people
engaged in this behavior actually
believe
and it is nearly impossible
for people in the midst of such
activities especially
emerging as they have after i mean at
this point the protests and riots have
been going on for longer than
the lockdowns did before they started
which is which is amazing
when they started it felt like well this
is how the end of lockdown will reveal
itself like no we're still you know
still in portland we're still in
phase one or something of reopening and
you know the schools are staying virtual
in all of this
um but people people who are engaging
this and even most of the rest of us
cannot begin to fathom how much of this
is about the manifestation of a mental
health crisis
a mental health crisis that is only
going to get worse here you know here we
are
in the northern temperate zone and
indeed for those of you who aren't in
the pacific northwest who have this
image of it being rainy all the time
we truly have the most beautiful summers
on the planet brett and i have been
you're not all over the planet but a lot
of places and there is
no place else we'd rather be july
august september it is it is gorgeous
and you know it has it this year has
been a little bit weird but um
you know in general clear blue skies and
80 degrees and
you know going down to 50 at night and
no humidity and just
completely gorgeous and it will become
dark
and cold and rainy and depressing
soon the days are getting short fast
shorter faster
now than they have been and the election
is coming
what is this going to look like the only
thing
that will keep the stuff going on the
streets in check is the fact that it
will be
harder for people to motivate to leave
their homes when it's
gross and cold outside but this this is
peak beauty here in the pacific
northwest it does make it easiest to get
out there but it's also the moment when
people are probably
at their mental health peak in general
in the year
and there's no end in sight to lockdowns
to virtual schooling to to being able to
go back to
live theater live music bars
clubs hanging out in restaurants inside
safely you know hanging out at
restaurants outside you know it's pretty
safe
and i know some of the restaurants are
open inside but
it's probably not safe so what what is
going to happen
it's it is it is a toxic toxic brew you
you said you know it's going to release
toxins when when they're sending fire to
this stuff yes it is
but it's also this release of energy
that is not in and of itself healthy
but is also not fully released yeah we
are we are headed for a calamity here
um zach can you put up the uh public
service announcement video
it shouldn't be that way honestly we
should be getting paid because we're
working so [ __ ] hard
so donate to us make sure these things
keep happening
and you keep coming out here and getting
more angry every day because black
people are still getting killed whether
you see it on the news or not
black people are dead so in that video
the person making the announcement makes
the claim and it's very familiar to us
from what happened at evergreen
in fact a lot of this is and i've seen
people comment on what is he saying uh
she is saying that the protesters should
be
paid for what they're doing um
and there is this sense yeah
you know there's it's just it's either a
complete lie
or it is a level of delusion that is
almost inconceivable that reminds me
i mean this is anecdotal we heard
several times that the protesters should
have been paid
at evergreen um but i also up in olympia
heard
um just anecdote but it struck me as
such a perfect perfect description of
the problem
that there was an employee at the local
food co-op
uh who was making trouble for everyone
and
also never showed up to work on time and
made more work for everyone and was you
know very much
very much an activist but at a place
that was
you know this is a a worker-owned
cooperative that had some of the best
you know best deals for food for people
and that's where we shopped when we were
there
out there and it was just very very hard
to get work done apparently in the
presence of this employee
and a friend of ours who worked there
said to me in all sincerity i just wish
that we could pay
for this employee to go and do
their activism somewhere else where they
could really be doing good in the world
and allow us to do the work that we need
to do here
like actually hoping for
payment within a you know a not very
well-funded people's food cooperative to
basically
offload to make this problem person an
externality into the rest of the world
so so much of this comes down to
a failure to extrapolate about the
simplest and most
obvious kinds of game theory but when
you have a
problem person who um people think well
maybe if we
pay them to be a problem elsewhere we
can get our work done they can do their
important thing
in effect that's what this protest is
this protest is a demand for a
transfer of resources power well-being
does anybody think that this this
movement
is composed only of good people
because if it was how would it not
accumulate
bad people given that that's what it's
angling for wouldn't it tend to attract
them of course
and so so but again with this mostly x
um configuration right like even if and
i don't think this is true
but even if black lives matter for
instance was started out in good faith
by
really good honest people who really
wanted only the best
for black people and saw the injustice
around uh policing that appeared to be
racially motivated and courts that were
still racially motivated in all of this
uh that that entirely benign
and good faith movement would come to
have some people
who would game the movement and then you
could still claim well
it's mostly good faith it's mostly doing
the right thing doesn't
matter bad faith actors win
even when they are a tiny minority in
fact they win less often at the point
that they become a majority this is
there's a there's a density dependent
issue here too that it's harder
to do to do your thing at the point that
you
are out you know you are becoming more
and more
densely represented within a population
if you are a bad faith actor
so it strikes me that we are seeing you
know i hear a lot of
metaphors and i've wielded uh many of
them myself i've
uh long argued that what we're seeing
are um trojan horse
arguments and i think that's a very
powerful way of seeing it but one i have
not heard
said very frequently is the wolf in
sheep's clothing
and i think we are seeing something
general of this form you know
so um you have a lot
of these rioters in fact it appears to
be
the great majority of the rioters are
white they are masquerading
as champions of black people which makes
them
almost impossible to challenge in the
current political environment
right because black people have
a real claim on long-standing injustice
systemic and otherwise
in this country so if you claim to be
standing with black people
then you can get away with crimes that
other people could not get away with and
that's happening
now for 80 some nights but we are also
seeing
you and i have trans friends they
want to be treated decently they want to
be able to navigate their lives
they want it not to be the only feature
of their lives that anyone ever talks
about right
they want it to be a feature
of their life at a similar level of
everybody else's sexuality where it's
not the
thing sex id yep yeah um
but we also have people who are clearly
abusing the category
in order to get away with all kinds of
obnoxious behavior so
that is to say um the
you know the dragon that is masquerading
as the damsel in distress
is a very difficult entity to fight
right
and so there you got a protected
category call me ma'am
right exactly um and so
there is um i don't know what
how obvious this would have to be in
order to be able to
get those of us together who want to
live in a decent civilization
and say actually we have an obligation
to put down
this protest because this protest is
simultaneously not what it appears to be
not what it claims to be
is engaged in i mean
i don't know how much clearer this could
be you have
people living in portland terrorizing
fellow portlanders in what universe is
that acceptable
even if those people who were being
terrorized held obnoxious beliefs
they are entitled to hold obnoxious
beliefs it's part of the freedom that
allows the system to work
but there's no evidence that these
people hold any obnoxious beliefs that
would warrant
any such thing so you have to put down
this protest but you can't do it because
somehow uh this tiny number of
routinely violent people is wielding a
totally phony story
and here's the key is that our
we have descended from a polarized
society in which there was overlap in
which we believed into a
discontinuous polarity where we don't
agree to the same facts
and that means that if you
are of the verificationist stripe where
you subscribe
to you know somebody who's going to
slant the news in a way that will make
you happy
then you do think there's a peaceful
protest in portland and that it's being
attacked by police
and that they successfully uh drove out
the feds who were sent by
trump with no provocation it is now
considered sufficient to know who said a
thing
to know what you think of it you do not
have to know what the words are what the
thought is what the idea is all you have
to know is the person
and that person has already been slotted
into i agree or i don't agree categories
and that's sufficient
and um you know i think this is part of
why we are we are confounding
uh to the extremes on on both sides
um because we won't say you know orange
man bad
and if trump said it has to be evil um
and we also won't abandon the fact that
we are actually progressives in the old
style of
of progressivism and but hold no truck
with this
nonsense authoritarian garbage that
threatens to destroy civilization
and uh most importantly i mean this is
implicit in what you just said but
most importantly we do not in any way
avoid the evidence
that comes from the other side right
right you've read candy
right yeah um so in fact that's that's
where we're going
we're going but yeah we need to connect
a few things up here so one i'm not done
reading candy unfortunately as part of
why my voice is like that i'm
still in it um
in a in a mafia movie if somebody comes
into the shop and they say oh it's a
beautiful shop it sure would be a shame
if something were to happen to it okay
it's a protection racket we all get it
that's the trope
right same thing is happening here where
you've got a protection racket
that is threatening people unless they
join up in some visible way and lend
their
fuel to that fire i should say
you know we've had this happen
personally we've received correspondence
at home
signed by people who claim to be antifa
and uh you know
done with the appearance of a greeting
card
um that is an amazing fact it's they're
obviously
it's meant to be taken as a threat and
um and it you know if
one says i've been threatened then it
can be taken as a greeting card if
that's what you're inclined
to do but at some level the words were
written on a greeting card
it's it's obviously a threat it's
obviously based on nothing if you pursue
the um claims of
the movement those claims
don't add up in even the most
superficial way and of course there's a
fail-safe claim at the bottom which is
that your attempt to evaluate claims
with logic is itself part of the problem
so the point is you know it's um it's
it's an infinite hall of mirrors in
which people are wielding
levers including threats of physical
violence
against people who haven't done anything
wrong
hiding you know wearing sheep's clothing
in order to maneuver
unfettered as wolves how obvious would
it have to be
right like it's completely obvious and
the problem is somehow mayor wheeler is
so
weak even though even though these
people are
i don't think i have it queued up but
calling for his head
sure metaphorically right wheeler is the
problem
he still won't do what he has to do and
say you know what enough's enough you
can't simply be lawless burn down what
you want break into buildings
at will walk through neighborhoods and
harass your neighbors we're
we're ending this now really other other
leaders should should take note
we we tried to encourage
you know we were really speaking to
other college presidents after evergreen
going like okay
this college president that we had at
evergreen was a disaster because he
sided with them
but he did so weekly and of course they
came for him when they didn't get the
outcome
they wanted this is exactly what
happened to wheeler in portland
and other mayors other college
presidents other leaders of any sort
take note pretending to be on their side
or even actually really thinking that
you're on their side you're going to
sign on as an ally and you're going to
do their bidding
you're not safe you will not be safe and
more to the point
because if you took that position with
any sense of good faith at all you were
supposed to be protecting your
constituents
or your students and faculty and staff
depending on what kind of organization
you're in charge of
you are doing the opposite of keeping
your people safe by doing that
you need to stand strong against this
stuff as early as you can
and then and back it up and that is not
to say that there isn't a place
for good faith protest we need that in a
democracy we 100 need it
but this this thing that is happening to
wheeler utterly predictable
totally utterly predictable he uh an
early version of this happened last
summer with the protests at the
ice buildings i think and uh he you know
he did exactly the same thing then
you know of course he's not going to win
against these people because they can
tell
that he doesn't really know what he's
doing and he's not really on their side
and also
this form of allyship is not really
ally it is you're useful until you're
not at which point we'll kick you to the
door
all right um before we move on uh i want
to point out you
read that description from coddling of
the american mind
known informally in some circles as
coddling the cuddling
uh about hawk newsome who had gone to
the
um the trump rally
as a blm um
supporter and had had that very
extraordinary interaction
now if you haven't seen the video of
that interaction you should
look it up just look up hawk newsome i'm
sure it's on youtube it'll be one of the
early results it's a an absolutely
beautiful thing
and i must say it represents a
possibility that hovers
everywhere right people are
in general decent and if you are willing
to give them a chance
they will very frequently give you a
chance and you can cross these bridges
and you and i have been doing this
it's extremely rewarding there's no
reason you shouldn't do it
however the tragedy of that
particular case is that
um hawk demonstrates on video and many
people saw it i mean it was like the
kind of stuff that brings you to tears
in an environment like this
that hawk obviously has that capacity
within him
as did the leader of the of the
pro-trump movement but i don't remember
his name absolutely
um however if you will check in
with hawk more recently he is no longer
of this mindset
and i think that this uh represents a
um really a catastrophe because
what do we see well so um you should
look up
a podcast that john wood jr who
if you're not familiar with him but that
sounds familiar you may remember him
from the black intellectual roundtable
that we did on darkhorse
so john wood jr uh is um
an ambassador for the organization
braver angels and the braver angels
podcast
uh john had bob woodson the friend of
ours
uh on with who was bob woodson
uh who marched with king in the 60s he's
a he's an original
civil rights uh activist from the 60s
he's an original civil rights activist
and
this is interesting he um marched with
king he was originally
very much on board and then he watched
the movement change and
he um parted ways with it and he's been
doing amazing work ever since so really
high quality work that has saved a great
many people
uh so but definitely speaking now from
from the right side of the aisle from
the aisle not the correct side the right
side so he's he's a republican now
he's he is but um at some level
he is on the personal responsibility
side of things on the other hand
personal responsibility demonstrably
works and he has been absolutely
tireless about this and the
um positive effect is undeniable so he
speaks with a great deal of credibility
um hawk newsome was having none of it
on this podcast so john wood jr is
leading a conversation between bob
woodson and hawk newsome okay yeah
and basically hawk newsome effectively
repudiates his openness that he
displayed
in the interaction with the trump
supporters when is this do you know
uh it's last three months
okay yeah i mean that this that's so sad
and it unfortunately reinforces the
point that i was trying to make which is
that
even even this this book that was
written two years ago well that was
published two years ago and written
you know two years and one and two years
before that
which was pointing out how dire a
situation we are in and was able to find
a couple of examples of
of good of good faith and openness
even those doors are closing right and
that we we just we are not seeing
anything of the kind of openness and
generosity of spirit
or imagining that other people have
intentions
and honorability just like you do
that we were even a couple of years ago
so
i think the thing that i'm getting out
of it
even in a very polarized environment
there are still things
on which you might agree
right in other words there are things
that are simply good for the nation and
we can be divided about a lot of stuff
but we should agree obviously on the
stuff that's good for all of us why
wouldn't we it'd be insane not to and it
would be crazy if there was nothing in
that category but
our style of interaction has now
produced
an assumption that if it's good for you
it's bad for me right
this can't help but be a disaster and
what it means
is that we are botching the stuff
that should be within our grasp right if
everybody feels
good when they watch a blm guy and a
trump
guy have a positive interaction in which
they come to agreement about the fact
that all lives are valuable
right if that makes people feel good you
would imagine there'd be a lot of it
because
it would be a you know but what
happens is one gets demonized
for it so if you have poles that are
serving their own interests
selfish poles that don't want us to find
common ground because it is not in their
interest that we do so
what they will do is they will demonize
you when you seek it
i must say this is in the unity 2020
context
um i have seen a huge outpouring of
patriotism and decency amongst people
who have gravitated to it
but i have also seen the most amazing
emergence of this bitter toxic
cynical despicable voice right
where people uh i mean look you can
disagree with unity 2020 if you want
right you could say well you know
it's too late you could say i don't
believe that you're
anti-spoiler uh measures are actually
going to work
uh so you know we have to reject it but
the thing that has come back
at me has been the accusation
that it is not a good faith proposal
that i am actually up to something that
i'm working for somebody or that i'm
trying to accomplish something
greedy or something like that and it's a
shocking thing but if you if you
take out the content of that accuracy
it's always the first
thing that shows up though isn't it i
mean we saw
we we've seen this and we've heard from
other friends who've gone through the
looking glass that that is one of the
first
if if you emerge and you're standing if
you have a movement that appears to be
that has some traction and has some
support the things that start getting
lobbed at you are you're working for
koch brothers right you're you know
you're part of the fox news network
you aren't what you say you are you're
grifting you know
all of these things will show up you're
serving your own interests yeah right
so i find this shocking though i mean on
the one hand i think it
basically you know if you take our motif
of you're very
often better off turning down the sound
on human interactions because you'll
understand better what's going on
in this case you can't really turn down
the sound but you can turn
down your focus on the uh actual content
of the accusations and you can
say when a party sees
its interest in division right when it
doesn't want unity
what will it do right it will drive up
the costs of
anything that tries to find common
ground
right and so the point is when you see
something seeking common ground
and then you see it taking fire from
outside
this is simply what it is somebody
doesn't want that middle ground
discovered
right they don't want the 70
of americans that the hidden tribes
report identifies as the exhausted
middle
that basically agrees on what direction
the country should go
doesn't want that thing to unify it
needs it divided and so
that um the punishing of
the honorable middle is just so
despicable
and um we should just we should name it
somehow and then just learn to recognize
it because
it's gonna happen every time and since
the only way out of this pickle
is finding some path in which we can do
what hawk newsom
uh did in that interaction where we can
cross bridges and find the humanity
in in our fellow americans or fellow
portlanders or whatever
if that's what has to happen then we've
got to be able to resist the accusations
that come back at you
when you attempt it yeah okay slight uh
slight pivot although it's all
um on a similar stuff uh today
zack if you would show that uh tweet
from james lindsay
just to start us off on this little
little segment uh so
hold on i can't see it there uh he's
just
quote tweeting someone who says there is
no way until we eradicate capitalism we
cannot eradicate white supremacy
capitalism is inherently a vehicle for
and created to spread white supremacy
okay so well then
um i found that absurd of course and it
just reminds us of what has now been
acknowledged
as uh some of the actually marxist roots
of the actual black lives matter
movement
but it's also true that capitalism is
plenty useful
um to those who are trying to gain power
and in fact they're going to need it
and as evidence here we have you know
pull up
sac that um nbc boston
article um twitter ceo jack dorsey
donates 10 million dollars to the
boston university center for anti-racist
research
the sub the sub headline being the
social media giant ceo and co-founder
donated 10 million dollars to a boston
university research center
founded by ibram x kenti to combat
racism
um note this is not to combat racism
that's what candy wants you to think
that's what
i don't know if jack actually thinks
that or not this is basically amounts to
a don't hurt me payment from jack
this is this is the same thing he needs
to look woke so that
so that no one comes after twitter at
some level maybe he believes it at this
point
it kind of doesn't matter um but no
despite what the headline says this is
not to combat racism
what it is quite explicitly this new uh
institute at boston university is to
promote anti-racism
and as we talked about in episode 39 at
some length
um this is this is candy's rhetorical
trap he's created a binary which is a
false one in which he said
if you are not anti-racist and eye candy
get to define anti-racist then you are
racist everything that is not
anti-racist with my special definition
is racist and if you don't quite
know this then you can mistake promoting
anti-racism for combating racism
right those those words those things
sound like they're the same thing but
but they're not um and if you think they
are
as presumably the authors of that nbc
article
um believe then you've fallen prey to
this rhetorical trap
of candies um so no once again you
should be opposed to racism
obviously uh and you should be opposed
to anti-racism which no was not in fact
a racist position
so um not only is this being
you know this is awful uh that we've got
a drop in the bucket
for for was it jack dorsey um
but it's gonna make a huge difference in
the efficacy of this
new organization that kendi has been
hired just this summer
to create at boston university
but it's also dangerous so zach would
you show the pdf
with the job announcements uh
for this uh thing
so oh boy i'm gonna have to pull it up
so i can see it um
yeah that would be great because i
cannot we can't see that
um it's still too small uh
here we go so here we have it the this
is
this was sent to us by um someone who's
at boston university who was asked to be
anonymized because like so many of the
people who are contacting us now they
say
i can't afford to lose my job i still
need to pay off my loans
i don't want to be cancelled by my
neighbors you know those are all
different things that we've heard from
different people
and um so this is this was from an
internal email
um to staff and faculty at boston
university uh for the center for
anti-racist research this
center that kendy has uh founded and
that jack dorsey has just contributed 10
million dollars to
and they're looking for associate
directors from within the boston
university faculty
uh they are now seeking two bu faculty
to serve in the following roles
the second one is the ones part of
particular interest zach if you would
scroll down to the associate director
of narrative the associate director of
narrative will lead the center's
narrative pillar which aims to foster
public scholarship that shifts the
racial narrative problematizing people
of
color so that itself is a
um is a claim that the
racial narrative there is a dominant
racial narrative problematizing people
of color
uh right now but maybe
more important is the idea that one of
the four pillars
of this work is narrative we've got
research
policy narrative and advocacy
and usually at a university you would
have
research and policy maybe policy would
be a separate sort of an institution
right maybe
what is it the john f kennedy school of
government at harvard i think
um which presumably does some policy
work uh
and um think tanks tend to do policy
when
when policy-oriented organizations are
within universities they are generally
a little bit isolated from the work of
the university which is research and
teaching which is about
truth-seeking so not only are research
and policy here together and and find
this maybe this is that sort of
institute but narrative
and advocacy and if you if you
click through onto some of the actual
uh links on the site you find that they
are talking about
uh training journalists and working to
get into extant journalistic outfits
with the with the narrative that they
will be creating
which strikes me as
so dangerous and so counter to what
should be happening in university that i
i can't believe i'm still surprised
frankly yeah
well it matches it is the type specimen
of everything
that we and others have been talking
about on this
front so
you cannot be as jonathan height has
clearly pointed out
you cannot be a university that is
focused on truth seeking at the same
time that you are focused
on um uh social justice that these
two things are distinct um and that they
are
they are in a trade-off relationship but
the very idea that this institute
is constituted around the idea
of research at all what is there to
research
right first of all we've already had the
conclusion spelled out
up front which is that anything that
isn't anti-racist
is racist okay so that claim ought to
make very clear that there is no
research to be done because that claim
is false and it already dictates the two
categories that things could go and
leaving no opportunity that anything is
anything else
worse the category of
um of anti-racist is specifically
defined by kennedy
as positive discrimination yeah
well it doesn't it not it doesn't have
to be um but anti-racist
is about equity and equity is about
equality of outcome so
when you know given that equality of
outcome
is what you need to be fighting for if
you are anti-racist
then positive discrimination is almost
certainly going to be a tool that you
need to
deploy right well and he specifically
says
oh he does it's just not it's just not
you know central you know positive
discrimination isn't central to the
definition but it's clearly all you have
to do is follow it one or two steps
and he does repeatedly in in the book so
an anti-racist uh we have said
repeatedly
that the problem with this movement is
that
it does not wish to end oppression it
wishes to turn the tables of oppression
and that this is specifically that put
in a form that is hard to fight
so i'm going to so i'm going to
i'm going to try to be candy here for a
minute and say well we're not trying to
turn the tables of oppression we're
trying to make everything
uh equitable that's certainly how could
you object to that aren't you just
trying to
maintain the position that your white
supremacy has granted you all of these
thousands of years my white supremacy my
white supremacy that i i sort of was
straight-faced
earned as my ancestors were being
persecuted by
the same white people that you're
complaining about my ancestors
uh who were literally being enslaved in
the heart of
europe in the middle of the last century
yeah those yeah that white supremacy
okay so and we put like
obviously that's easy to to to knock
down not that
anyone else seems to be doing it but um
what do you do with the argument that
will come back no we're not trying to
turn the tables of oppression we're just
trying to make things
right well first of all i would just say
uh
game theoretically speaking no you
cannot do this second of all if you were
even
trying to do this you would be spelling
out an end point
right because the you know the problem
and they are the
the end point is equality of outcome in
every regard right except for the game
theory because if you set up a quality
of hours well no so the game theory says
explains why you can't get there but i
think that
that is the stated goal i would say more
relevant than the game theory says why
you can't get there actually your stated
goal
isn't yet fully stated enough because it
requires
exactly the racial categories that you
all
you know legitimately complain about
criticize
and you know what how how is it that we
will keep dividing these spaces up and
you know this is part of what the tr the
rise in trans activism is about right
how is it we will keep on dividing these
spaces up so that now
you know it's only disabled trans people
from the pacific islanders who are
underrepresented
in college administrations and therefore
we definitely have to hire one of them
here so you know
if if you can continue to make new
categories all the time there is no
endpoint and there is no
there there is no win that is even
imaginable but
um you know put put that aside even if
you had stable racial categories which
like who wants that
but even if you had them uh you won't
get there because
it will fail because of game theory well
yes it will it will fail
because of a massive collection
collective action problem
and a free rider issue which is if you
demand equality of
outcome then the person who profits most
is the person who invests least
so you you're basically setting up a
system
of freeloading that has no mechanism
for uh for policing and so
anyway the whole thing is so obviously
wrong at such a simple level that nobody
as smart as jack dorsey could possibly
believe it but here's the here's the the
thing that i get from this dorsey bit
you point out this is a small amount of
money to him it is a huge amount of
money
in an academic context and the vast
majority of us
right um and the point though
is it follows the exact same pattern
as what people are now doing in much
more mundane ways
a thousand times a day in every
institution in
the western world which is they are
solving their own
problem by making a gesture that is then
empowering the movement that then comes
after the next person
so that they will solve their own pr
problem and make a gesture so
point is look i hate to say it right
it's very easy for those of us who don't
have the kind of money that jack dorsey
does
to misunderstand what it would be like
to be in his shoes but in this case i
have to say
jack dorsey has enough money that he can
set himself up
for life he can insulate himself
completely from people showing up in his
neighborhood frankly he can move
wherever he wants in the world and uh be
safe by virtue of the kinds of things
that that kind of
resource will buy for him to
externalize harm on others for him to
empower a movement that is threatening
other people
by giving them a token amount of money
for him
and a huge sum for them he basically
just
um hurt the rest of us by
creating a huge amount of
pseudo-legitimacy so what i've called
idea laundering
an institute at bu that's studying
anti-racism for the point of view
for the purpose of generating policy
and writing narratives this is nonsense
and jack you just
threw a whole bunch of gasoline on that
fire presumably to solve your own
problem
and it it's uh it's absolutely
unacceptable
i'm reminded of the famous um i want to
know how to pronounce his name martin
niemoller do you know how to pronounce
this guy's name
uh first they came for the socialists uh
quotation so let me just read it first
and then say what i hear
you saying as the modern update which is
just
horrifying so he wrote no i'll just read
it
but you can show it sure first they came
for the socialists and i did not speak
out because i was not a socialist
then they came for the trade unionists
and i did not speak out because i was
not a trade unionist
then they came for the jews and i did
not speak out because i was not a jew
then they came for me and there was no
one left to speak for me
well the update uh that you were
suggesting that jack dors everyone from
jack dorsey to the people with uh
blm signs on their lawn who put it up
for fear that they would be the
people who would next see the lights
shined in their windows and be told to
get on the streets or else they aren't
part of the
right side here first they came for the
socialists and i
you know first they came to the
socialists and not only did i not speak
out
i explained to them why the socialists
were wrong
then they came for the trade unionists
and only didn't i not speak out but i
explained to them why the trade
unionists were wrong
then they came for the jews and i did
not speak out and i also explained to
them why the jews were wrong
and they came for me and there was no
one left to speak for me it's not quite
right but there's
some horrifying update to his
to his comment from the holocaust that
people are engaging in now that is even
worse than just being silent
it is people actually offloading uh
the well-being of their neighbors and
the rest of society in order to protect
themselves for a very brief moment
yeah it's uh it's it's a increase
instead of your cowardice leaving others
vulnerable
it's uh whatever the active version of
cowardice is while you're where you're
bending over backwards to make life
easy for um the people wielding the
threat
you are in effect increasing the power
of that threat against
um the next people in line and i have to
say
um just i i don't i see
an awful lot of cowardice at the very
top the people who can afford
best not to be cowards yeah are in fact
most reliable in this respect that they
are the most likely
to bend over backwards and i i think
it's some perverse version
of because they have a huge amount
stored up they're calculating how much
they would lose
rather than how safe they actually are i
mean if you can buy your own security
force
yeah you know you can put your house you
know on a hill and surround it with
guards and whatever else you're doing
you're in a much better position to say
the truth than those of us who
can't do that and some of us are
standing up so what the hell
i mean seriously if we can't depend on
somebody like jack dorsey
to say you know what that anti-racism
stuff you're selling
isn't anti-racism anti-racism if that
word is to mean anything would have to
be
an end to racism it doesn't it's not
some new
racism that counters racism until some
you know utopian future point well it's
i mean it's related to the truism that
there's sort of a rolling goal that i
don't remember if it's from corporate
america
or from from tech billionaire space but
people will say you know until
until you have your first million you
imagine that that will be enough and
then you get your first million and
uh they say oh well now i need five
million i i can't remember this sort of
emerges from the 80s maybe
um in um in corporate landscapes
uh where people you know become rich and
then realize that rich isn't what they
thought it was and they need more and
more and more and so
you don't you know maybe even jack
dorsey doesn't even feel like he's safe
right uh yeah
i'm not i'm i'm not justifying it i get
it you know
but on the other hand this is a this is
an international
emergency and if we can't depend on
the smart people of silicon valley to
figure out that western civilization is
coming apart at the seams
that they have played some role in
allowing that to happen and they have
some
obligation to the rest of us to put it
right that you know
we are now you know at each other's
throats in the streets of
major american cities people are fleeing
those cities this is
insane and people like jack dorsey have
an obligation to stand up first not last
yeah okay one more thing before we stop
before we take a break here
okay um zach would you show the
abc the australia uh
tech article that i gave you yes
hotel quarantine officer quit over
coronavirus safety concerns as inquiry
hears of dehumanizing experiences
uh first just the first paragraph here
an authorized officer put in charge of
hotel quarantine operations at melbourne
hotels says he completed diversity
training but was given no formal
instructions on how to use personal
protective equipment
and there's a there's a video which you
know we'll link to this in
the description or pinned uh comment on
this video
wherein you can see this um in which he
is asked by
uh an investigator okay what what what
were you exposed to well you know i
got training in the app and i got
trading in diversity
inclusion and equity how do you get
training and what the virus is or how to
help people to get training
in and how to use ppes how to distribute
them
no no no no no so um and of course
there's
this this is coming in the wake of these
big outbreaks
that are happening exactly there but but
for which maybe we would never even know
right uh it should it should
go without saying that if you are trying
to reduce the spread of a virus
that educating the people who are in
charge of reducing the spread of the
virus
should receive education in biology and
health
before they receive training in
diversity equity and inclusion the virus
doesn't care
the virus does not care i cannot believe
we are here
i i i'm just i'm gobsmacked and i'm not
even british
yeah and it's not it's not just here
it's
it's everywhere um i saw
recently an expose um
turned into i think rufo is the name of
the uh
the person who brought it to light the
um department of energy
is doing these trainings on
uh you know the the scourge of
whiteness schools of engineering this is
this is what we need civil engineers
um who are more focused on the sex and
race of the people building the bridges
as opposed to whether or not they
actually are enumerate themselves
i don't want enumerate bridge builders
no and there will be enumerate bridge
builders
along every demographic line and there
will be numerous bridge builders along
every demographic line what we need to
focus on
is skill in engineering not the
demographics
yep now you do need to have no racism
in the system at the level of hiring if
you did have racism it wouldn't
necessarily cause bridges to fall down
it wouldn't be good though i mean if you
had racism it would prevent you from
hiring the best people
which should be the objective but
obviously
if there's a problem it needs to be
addressed but the assertion that it is a
problem because everything
uh must contain this this you know this
ghost
is absurd and you know it's challenging
our ability to
manage nuclear weapons and you know
reactors i mean this is
this is we are playing with nuclear fire
yeah and schools and maybe next time
we've heard from a lot of parents
recently uh from across the western
world who are seeing this show up in
their kids schools
for the first time explicitly right now
i think rather than it's been going on
and they're just noticing it but it is
you know especially right now because
parents are seeing more of their kids
stuff because a lot of schools are
virtual
uh it is uh it is cropping up even
more explicitly than it has been for a
while and uh
and it's it's terrifying uh i think i
think we're stopping there
well i mean to say two more things
before we go
um one i want to just connect up a
thread
that just as it is true that we should
be eager to find places on which
we have agreement that allow us to move
forward on that which is in everybody's
interest and we're not having that
because our level of polarization is now
discontinuous
you have two separate stories that don't
reconcile this is really the explanation
for what happened to us
with respect to covet 19.
that what happened was instead of
recognizing oh my god this is a
dangerous situation we don't fully
understand it but we certainly have an
interest in containing this as well as
possible
we got two versions both of which turn
out to be wrong
one was very focused on the uh the rate
of
death which was the wrong focus and
that undercut the developing
understanding
of the hazard that this poses in other
ways the brain damage the
circulatory system damage the long-term
consequences
which to be fair would have been less
obvious early on
sure but the point is we all had an
interest in finding out what the actual
damage and risk was but the basic point
was you know
half of us who were very concerned about
this were being treated as nervous
nellie's we turned out to be right about
the danger but the danger wasn't where
we initially thought
um so and i interrupted you half you
know and then the other extreme
was there's not a problem at all there's
not a problem it's just kind of a flu
right and so you know as we've talked
about before
when i walk around uh outdoors here in
the summer with the sun shining and i
see person after person
walking by in their masks i feel like
stopping each of them and just saying
you know what
outdoors you're not it's not like you're
standing and talking to somebody
you know face to face walking around
outdoors you should take that mask off
because
you're gonna need to wear it at times
you don't want to so
you know this is the the right moment so
anyway you've got people who are sort of
broadcasting their failty to the mask
wearing regime rather than
even on bikes right so the four of us
went on a long bike ride yesterday and
the number of people we
passed when we were on a bike path uh
who
were wearing masks was surprising to me
well it is surprising
and it just you know it's it's a
needless cost
and you know and they look at us as
scans we we may have masks around our
necks
but they look at us like we're on the
other team and it's like no
no no no we're just doing what the
science suggests would be the wise thing
to do
but anyway this would be so different if
we were having a national conversation
about the developing
understanding of kovid and how to
address it in the least
psychologically and physically harmful
way possible
instead of having two teams both of
which aren't making sense
so anyway i i don't know what the
distinction is between a very polarized
situation in which there's still an
understanding of
there being some common interest and one
in which
if it's good for you it's bad for me and
that's the only thing i'm sure of
right that thing and everything that's
good for you is bad for me
not just if that thing is good for you
it's bad for me but everything that's
good for you is bad for me
everything that's good for you is bad
for me so i'm gonna root you know if
if your guy gets elected i'm gonna root
against him yeah like how
dumb would you have to be to root
against the country fails
right wow no you should be rooting to be
pleasantly surprised
right and uh wow okay so that brings me
to the last issue
unity 2020 we have uh
nominated six people we are now on our
site having an active discussion about
which of them
we should uh put on our ticket and
attempt to draft
um so anyway this is a very exciting
moment the actual drafting should occur
soon if you want to be in on it sign up
at our site
with your email address site being
the site being articlesofunity.org
you can also follow us on twitter at
articles of
unity and certainly join us for
our campfires the last one with dan
crenshaw um was great
would be wonderful if tulsi had been
able to join us she was not but
hopefully
tulsi dan eric and i will gather for a
future
campfire soon and there will be one
tomorrow at i think
six uh pacific uh with as of yet
unspecified
guests yes yes okay
um all right i think i think we've come
to the end then we will as
we do take a 15 or so minute break uh
collect your super chat questions that
came in this hour and encourage you to
submit superchat questions for the next
hour as well
we will answer them uh as many as we can
get through
in the following hour we encourage you
if you enjoy the q and a's and uh would
like to
be present for one that's a little bit
more intimate we do a private one once a
month
for people who subscribe to my patreon
the next one will be not tomorrow but a
week from sunday
and you can also access a private
discord server at either of our patreons
and what else i think that's it
all right all right we'll see you in
about 15 minutes